Let's do some problems that
deal with equations and
inequalities.
So let's start with this
problem 2 here.
So it says define the variables
and translate the
following expressions
into inequalities.
Let's see, part a: A bus can
seat 65 passengers or fewer.
So in Part a, let's let x be
the number bus can seat.
So the number of people you
can sit in the bus, we're
going to call that x.
And they're saying that
the bus can fit
65 people or fewer.
So x has to be less than
or equal to 65.
And we put that equal there,
that less than or equal,
because it could be 65.
It doesn't say definitely
less than 65.
It could be 65 passengers
or fewer.
So that's why it's less
than or equal to.
b: the sum of two consecutive
integers is less than 54.
So if you say x is first
integer, and then x
plus 1 is the next.
They're saying the sum of these
two is less than 54.
So x plus 1 is less than 54.
And if you actually wanted to
figure out what x is, what the
first integer is, you could just
solve this inequality.
c: an amount of money is
invested at 5% annual
interest. Let x be the
amount of money.
It's invested at 5% annual
interest. The interest earned
at the end of the year is
greater than or equal to $250.
So what's the interest earned
at the end of the year?
It's the amount of money you
invest times your annual
interest rate, times 5% or, if
you write this as a decimal ,
it's 0.05 So 0.05 or 5% times
the amount of money invested,
that is going to be greater than
or equal to-- this is the
amount of interest earned --that
is going to be greater
than or equal to $250.
So that's what we did.
We set up the problem
into an inequality.
And part d.
You buy hamburgers at a
fast food restaurant.
A hamburger costs $0.49.
You have at most
$3.00 to spend.
Write an inequality
for the number of
hamburgers you can buy.
So let's change the letters.
Let h be equal to the number
of hamburgers.
So the total I'm going to
spend is the number of
hamburgers times the amount
per hamburger, times 0.49.
That's the total amount I'm
going to spend, and that can
at most be $3.00.
So it has to be less than
or equal to $3.00.
So that is our inequality.
Let's do problem 4 here.
Check that the given number
is a solution to the
corresponding inequality.
All right.
Part a here.
So the inequality is 2 times
x plus 6 is less
than or equal to 8x.
And they're saying that x is
equal to 12 is a solution.
Let's verify that.
So if you put a 12 here-- do it
in a different color --if
this is a 12 and then
this would be a 12.
So you get 2 times 12 plus 6.
So this is 2 times 18 is less
than or equal to 8 times 12.
8 times 12 is 96.
2 times 18 is 36.
So 36 is definitely less
than or equal to 96.
So this x is equal to
12 is a solution.
Part b.
We have 1.4 times z plus 5.2
is greater than 0.4z.
For the solution, if z is equal
to minus 9-- negative 9
I should say.
I always say minus 9.
The correct wording
is negative 9.
So let's put a negative
9 here.
So it's 1.4-- they're saying
that that's one of the
solutions --times negative 9
plus 5.2 is greater than 0.4
times negative 9.
And I'm just going to use the
calculator on this one just
for the sake of time.
You could do that in your
head if you like.
So we have on the left-hand
side, 1.4 times negative 9.
That's equal to minus 12.6.
So this is minus is 12.6 plus
5.2 is equal to negative 7.4.
So this left-hand side
is negative 7.4.
Then they're claiming that that
is greater than-- This I
can do in my head.
4 times 9 is 36.
I'm going to have to put a
negative sign because it's a
positive times a negative.
And I have one number behind
the decimal point.
So this is saying negative 7.4
is greater than negative 3.6.
This isn't true.
If you draw a number
line right here.
So if this is 0, this
is negative 3.6,
this is negative 7.4.
It's less than negative 3.6.
So this is not true.
I'll do it in a big red color.
That is not true.
z is equal to negative 9 is
not a solution of this
inequality right there.
It does not satisfy
that inequality.
Part c.
They have minus 5/2 y plus 1/2
is less than negative 18.
And they're claiming y is
equal 40 is a solution.
Let's try that out.
So minus 5/2-- instead of y I
can write 40 just to see if it
works --plus 1/2 is less
than minus 18.
That's their claim.
So 5/2 times 40-- Divide
the numerator and
denominator by 2.
So 1 becomes a 20.
So it becomes minus 5 times 20
is minus 100 plus 1/2 is less
than minus 18.
Well, you could view this
as negative 99 and 1/2.
You could do that in your head
if you like, or you could view
this as 99.5-- you're adding
0.5 to minus 100 --is less
than negative 18, which
is definitely true.
This is more negative
than this is.
So this is correct.
And then finally part d.
Let me scroll down or let me
clear some space for myself.
Part d.
They're saying 80 is greater
than or equal to 10
times 3t plus 2.
And they're claiming that t is
equal to 0.4 as a solution.
Let's try that out.
80 is greater than or equal
to 3 times 0.4 plus 2.
So that's saying that 80 is
greater than or equal to 10
times-- 3 times 0.4 is 1.2
--plus 2, or 80 is greater
than or equal to 10 times--
This is 3.2.
Or that 80 is greater than
or equal to 32, which is
absolutely right.
So d is also a valid solution.
Problem 5.
The cost of a Ford Focus
is 27% of the
price of a Lexus GS450H.
If the price of a Ford is
$15,000-- So the Ford is equal
to $15,000, what is the
price of a Lexus?
So they tell us that the Ford
is equal to 27% of the price
of the Lexus.
Is equal to 0.27, or 27%, times
the price of a Lexus.
I could write F and L,
but I'll just write
out the words there.
So the Ford we know
is $15,000.
So we know that $15,000 is equal
to 27%, 0.27, times the
price of a Lexus.
So to figure out the price of
a Lexus we just divide both
sides by 0.27, and divide
this side by 0.27.
That just becomes a 1.
And so you have the price of
your Lexus is equal to $15,000
divided by 0.27.
See what we get.
So let me clear it.
We have 15-- 1, 2, 3, $15,000
divided by 0.27 is equal to
$55,555.55.
So we'll say $55,556
just to round up.
So this is equal to $55,556.
So you're spending a lot more on
the Lexus than you would on
the Ford Focus.
It better be a much
better car.
Finally, number 6.
On your new job you can be
paid in one of two ways.
All right.
You can either be paid--
So this is option one.
And let's write option 2 here.
You can either be paid $1,000
per month plus 6% commission
of total sales.
So let's let s is equal
to total sales.
So your first option you'll be
paid $1,000 per month plus 6%
of total sales.
So on a monthly basis you'll
be paid $1,000 plus 6% of
total sales.
So plus 6% times your
That's option 1.
That's right there.
You can either be paid $1,000
per month plus 6% commission
of total sales.
And then option 2 is
$1,200 per month--
Let me switch colors.
Option 2-- I'll do it in yellow
--paid $1,200 per month
plus 5% commission on
sales over $2,000.
Let me scroll over
a little bit.
Plus 5% of sales over $2,000.
So if my sales are s, my sales
over $2,000 are going to be s
minus $2,000.
If my sales are, let's say
they're $3,000 in a month.
The sales over $2,000
are going to be
$3,000 minus $2,000.
It's going to be $1,000
over $2,000.
So these are our two options.
Let me highlight that
right over there.
And they say for what amount of
sales is the first option
better than the second option?
And assume they're always
sales over $2,000.
So they're essentially saying,
OK, this is always going to be
non-0 right here.
So we want to know the situation
where the first
option is better.
Better, probably meaning
for me, meaning that
I'll get more money.
So when is option 1 going to
be, we could either say
greater than or greater than
or equal to, option 2.
And then we could solve
this equation.
So let's see what we can do.
The first thing, let's subtract
$1,000 from both sides.
If you subtract $1,000 from the
left-hand side you're just
left with 0.06s is greater than
or equal to-- So subtract
$1,000 from the left-hand
side.
I'll take the $1,000
from here.
You're left with 200 plus 0.05
times s minus 2,000.
And then let's see, I probably
want to multiply that out.
This is going to be 200 plus
0.05s minus-- This 0.05,
that's the same 5%, that's
the same thing as 1/20.
1/20 of 2,000, that's 100.
So this is minus 100.
That times that is 100.
I'm just distributing this
5% or this 0.05.
So that's the right-hand
side of the equation.
On the left-hand side we have
0.06, and we just simplify the
right-hand side a little bit.
We have 200 minus 100, so that
just becomes 200 minus 100, we
could just write as plus
100 right there.
So our equation is 0.06 is
greater than or equal to
0.05-- Sorry, this is 0.06s is
greater than or equal to-- I
don't want to lose that s over
there --0.05s plus 100.
Now let's subtract 0.05s from
both sides of the equation.
So 0.06 minus 0.05s is going to
be 0.01s is greater than or
equal to-- I subtracted this
from both sides, so it's not
going to be here anymore --is
greater than or equal to 100.
And now I just divide
both sides by 0.01.
So 0.01, 0.01.
That becomes a 1.
And then we are left with s is
to going to be greater than or
equal to-- What's 100
divided by 0.01?
This is the same thing as 100
divided by 1 over 100, which
is the same thing as
100 times 100.
100 times 100 is 10,000.
So option 1 is definitely better
for you if your total
sales for the month,
if s is greater
than or equal to $10,000.
If it's less than that you're
better with option 2.